Cley Ron Rivera the Washington coach
yesterday did a video conference and he
said that he will support players who
kneel for the anthem again I think this
is something that the owners need to be
saying and secondly how do you do and
look I don't want to be overly critical
in my peers in the media cuz I
understand a press conference setting
there's a lot of well I'll defer to
someone else who asked this question how
does nobody ask Ron Rivera what are your
feelings as a minority what are your
feelings on the name of your team he
needs to be on the record about that
somebody needs to ask him what do you
think about a team name that you work
for that is a dictionary defined slur he
hasn't been asked that question
yesterday a perfect opportunity to do it
right Kris am I wrong
no you're not you're not wrong it's kind
of like the the 10,000 pound elephant in
the room certainly and you know I'd like
to hear his answer legitimately I would
I'm not so sure he wants to give an
answer that's a tough spot for him to be
in there it really is but yeah I'd like
to hear that and someone doesn't need to
ask him well maybe we'll try to find a
way to present the question to him
although I may not like the answer the
answer right now Ron's a great guy Ron's
a great great guy and and and I just it
was an opportunity that was lost
yesterday for him to not be asked that
question a simple question and that's
gotten lost in all this look folks if if
if we're taking a stand against racism
it's it's all races that experience it
who aren't in the majority and this is
one thing that is glaring and it's out
there and if we truly are changing you
look at what NASCAR did yesterday no
more confederate flags at any NASCAR
events that's the kind of seismic
shifting that we need to see and I think
the NFL between Colin Kaepernick and the
name of the Washington franchise that
they're looking like they are beat they
are leading from behind as they often
are accused of doing all right we're
gonna take a break up next on the Chris
Sims quarterback top 40 countdown number
17 a guy who coincidentally wears number
17 that probably wasn't one of the
factors in the decision process but with
Sims who the hell knows more pfff right
after this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports